Have you seen this
bulletproof train
that the North Korean dictator
is riding around in?
It's bulletproof.
It's huge.
And it's what
the North Korean leader uses
to leave the country
because he's kind of afraid of flying.
Or at least that's the rumor.
Kim Jong-un
hasn't left the country in three years,
but he just decided to do so.
To go to Russia.
To visit President Vladimir Putin.
He snaked up the coast of North Korea
past this really bizarre place
where China, Russia and North Korea borders
all come together
and eventually made it to Eastern Russia.
By the way,
this train
only goes like 30
or 40 miles an hour max speed
because they want it to be extra safe.
Kim is reportedly joined
by his munitions and weapons
guy leading many experts to speculate
that this trip is about Russia
asking North Korea for weapons.
Reminder that Vladimir Putin
is very isolated from the world right now
and is struggling to get the weapons
and materials
he needs to continue his war in Ukraine.
So he's turning to a fellow
outcast, North Korea, for help.
So now we just wait and see
if North Korean weapons
start flowing into Russia.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow for more.